[Music]
we've tapped into their radios we can
confirm two divisions confirmed live an
aerial visual copy yes yes we can hear
them moving in only none of what the
Germans thought they could see or hear
was real during World War two a secret
division of the US Army now known as the
ghost army conducted over 20 tactical
operations which resulted in saving tens
of thousands of lives the mission to
trick the enemy into thinking that their
unit of 1,000 men was actually two
divisions of 30,000 men but the ghost
army wasn't made up of traditional
soldiers the majority were actors
designers advertisers and artists who
had been recruited from the top art and
design schools around the country and
this army of artists use their
creativity for an infantry of illusion
engineers developed inflatable tanks
which the artists would then paint these
tanks could condense down to fit into a
portable bag and inflate on demand much
like a bouncy castle audio engineers use
large speakers to play sound effects of
Tanks and marching soldiers which had
been pre-recorded at Fort Knox
this marching army could be heard from
miles away along with fake radio
messages sent in to the signals of the
enemies they would also send actors
dressed as generals and officers into
local towns to spread false information
and rumors it wasn't until 1996 when
information about the Gerst
army was Declassified that the world
finally knew about these masters of
misdirection the unsung heroes of World
War two
[Music]
at the end of World War two the Soviets
were holding Berlin under siege in order
to save millions of people from
starvation the US and allies devised a
plan to airlift in food one American
pilot decided to take it a step further
he delivered candy my name is Gail
Halvorsen but I'm known as the Berlin
candy bomber
I didn't think what you know that's the
last very long so I thought I'd better
get a movie of this operation before
they send me home one day while filming
the planes taking off and landing Gale
became aware that there was some young
children watching him he went over to
talk to them and after a while he
realized dummy don't you know kids like
chocolate and I knew that then I had
chocolate the stores in Berlin for two
years and I refused my pocketknife all I
had was two sticks of Wrigley's double
minigun and I broke the two sticks and a
half gave the kids and the kids would
have a stick tore off the wrapper the
thin strips and passed it to those a lot
gum those who received the wrappers put
it up their nose and smelled a piece of
wrapper
inspired by their generosity he decided
that next flight he would drop them
chocolate and candy via parachute from
the plane
they said how do we know what what are
playing your head and so I said when I
come over the airfield or wiggle or that
big airplane they said old grape true to
his word the next day Gale began to drop
the packages what started with just two
sticks of gum eventually turned into 23
tons of chocolate then on I was normally
a person all the kids in Berlin that's
not politely wings and in case you were
wondering if the candy bomber still has
a sweet tooth oh yeah I saw these
chocolate I like doctors here that that
is a military code of the Choctaw Nation
can understand it neither could the
Germans
[Music]
our story starts in the Western Front
during World War one the Allies are in
trouble
the Germans had tapped their phone lines
and deciphered their codes as the Allies
struggled to find a solution one captain
overheard two of his Native American
Choctaw soldiers speaking their mother
tongue and the captain overheard the two
soldiers speaking their native language
they probably thought they were in
really big trouble
that's new chena Shobha hi there
great-granddaughter one of those two
soldiers and president of the Choctaw
code talkers Association around this
time if we talk to our rakaat speaking
the language they were liable to be sent
away to a re-education program but the
captain he had a different idea
if I can't understand what they're
saying perhaps the Germans won't
understand what they're saying the US
military began transmitting tactical
messages in Choctaw and unsurprisingly
the Germans could not break the code
not our military terms had a direct
Choctaw translation machine gun was
little guns shoot fast ammonition auskey
was arrows and gas bottle was bad air
and due at least in part to the Choctaw
code talkers in their neologisms the war
ended soon thereafter when you look at
how ironic it is for the government to
say you can't speak your language but
yet they used them to help win world war
one that's pretty amazing to me
[Music]
[Applause]
when I realized that monuments of those
who served our country and fought for
the freedoms that we enjoy today were in
disrepair in poor condition it upset me
it's sad to see that they've been
forgotten completely most of them are
unreadable so no one can tell who they
are what they did and how they served
our country and what they meant to our
country if you find a gleaming stone
that maybe a hundred or 150 years old
there's a good chance that I've probably
been there
[Music]
my name is Andrew Loomis you're better
known as the good cemetery in' i restore
the monuments of veterans who served in
multiple conflicts for our country and
their families i complete restorations
on my day off typically which is sunday
i've restored between five and six
hundred monuments to date living in the
south there is a multitude of things
that accumulate on a given stone it may
have more than a hundred years of
buildup and mildew and mold it's very
tedious it's very hard work soaking a
stone with water scrubbing with brushes
their toothbrushes and q-tips a monument
restoration typically will take between
two and four months but there's nothing
that makes me feel as good as when I
complete a restoration the reason I
began doing this is for both personal
and historical reasons I have friends
who served and friends who I lost both
in battle and combat and friends who
lost their battle once they came back
home it's important to me to see that
they can be remembered and not forgotten
the monuments themselves are not just
stones you know I want to uncover who
they were as a human being as a person
in addition to their sacrifice in their
service to our country because they
weren't just soldiers either they were
Americans first they were soldiers
second I can't allow that to be
forgotten
[Music]
[Music]
there's something about being part of
nature there's something about being
around these animals to even the most
wounded veteran they feel different
keeps them part of something greater
than themselves the idea is that you've
got to give someone who's been through a
severe trauma an opportunity to heal and
we believe that warriors and wolves
program and a back to nature setting it
does that we have 40 animals at this
facility we've rescued wolves off of
chains in Alaska as part of a roadside
attraction we rescued wolf dogs from a
backyard breeder in San Diego I think
for all the veterans that we bring out
here whether they work here or they're
here for a support group what rings true
is if they can heal I can use the Wolves
the nullus you're injured or something's
wrong with you and they have that trauma
so you know we had some type of trauma
on life we can't get that connection and
one wolf would be your friend for life
what happens is one animal picks that
one veteran never again does that animal
pick someone else never again does that
animal want to show the same kind of
affection to someone else boy
conventional therapy isn't really
something for me didn't help to be
honest after ten years of military life
it was sort of a tough transition and I
continued down my course of being angry
drinking myself to death may have been
last chapter of my life
[Music]
there are things I've seen that I can't
unsee there are things I've done that I
cannot undo just saying that well I did
it in the name of my country doesn't
help you sleep at night but what does
help you sleep is having a companion
they kind of teach you how to be calm
and confident it's it's got some deeper
meaning when they accept you they accept
you into the family part of the pack
[Music]
you remember this can the sweet sauce
the soft noodle this twist childhood but
did you know that Chef Boyardee was an
actual chef he was his name was Hector
and he made a mean pasta sauce but it
wasn't Hector sauce that made Chef
Boyardee the household name that it is
today
you can think the US military for that
in the 1930s
Hector BRD opened up an Italian
restaurant in Ohio and everyone was like
oh my god I love your sauce so he
started selling it and he sold a lot of
it a lot a lot by 1938 he had opened up
his own factory selling his sauce and
pasta
Cantus asked for Chef Boyardee spaghetti
dinner only about 15 cents a serving
then World War two happened and a phone
call was made
the US military called Hector had said
something like help make food for the
troops he already had the Kenyan
infrastructure so Hector said all right
his company shifted from a civilian
consumer base to a military one Chef
Boyardee became the largest supplier of
rations to US and Allied forces
production was happening 24/7 by the end
of the war the factory was too large and
the military demand no longer existed
Hector didn't know what to do so he sold
it to this large company called American
Home Products who were all like we got
this they quickly rebranded and
distributed the can as easy to make at
home meals and filled supermarket
shelves across the United States so
today when we buy Chef Boyardee we're
actually eating rebranded World War two
field rations yep
[Music]
you